hello my name is deborah rubin and i'll
be talking today about the work that our
team is doing to integrate data and
analysis on the cross-cutting themes of
gender equality youth engagement
nutrition and resilience with the
innovation lab for crop improvement or
ilc
let me take a moment to introduce you to
our team the core members consist of a
multi-disciplinary group of researchers
from agricultural science and the social
sciences together we have a strong
record of field research that documents
the needs of small farmers processors
traders and consumers we have all helped
to translate that knowledge and
experience into the approaches of
agricultural research we've also
conducted many workshops with
researchers and practitioners on
integrating cross-cutting themes into
many aspects of agricultural development
our extended team consists of scientists
working with each center of innovation
who have different disciplinary
trainings and national backgrounds
currently based across eight countries
the cross-cutting themes work that we do
draws on the work of others as well as
our own some of which is displayed here
i'm taking time to point out this
historical record because i am so often
faced with people who think that
attention to cross-cutting themes is
simply a new fad in agricultural science
when it actually represents quite a
large body of work over a long period of
time
and those studies are founded on
rigorous data collection both
qualitative and quantitative conducted
in major agricultural research programs
implemented around the world
in our work at ilse we are building on
work carried out by field researchers
before us who sought to ensure that
farmers and other rural residents both
men and women were active participants
in the research process
although too many to name here we
recognized researchers who sought to
systematically identify preferences of
smallholder farmers and to incorporate
that information into breeding efforts
other pioneering researchers deserve
credit for explicitly recognizing the
importance of women's work in
agriculture not only for women's
contributions to family food security
and income but also as actors in seed
selection pest and disease control and
managing soil fertility three
characteristics that link to breeders
efforts in developing new varieties
it is against the backdrop of this large
body of scientific research that ilc
designed its approach to integrating
cross-cutting themes
diversity and social inclusion are
foundational principles
on which the cross-cutting themes rest
as steve kresovich the ilc director has
said the difference between crop
breeding and crop improvement lies in
part in the latter's incorporation of
agricultural life and social sciences to
achieve the goal of generating germplasm
that increases benefits to those who are
most marginalized
from inception the lc project has
supported the work of its researchers to
address the four cross-cutting themes of
gender equality youth engagement
nutrition and resilience
significant research has been done on
each of these themes in agriculture
less work has been devoted to
specifically to these themes in breeding
and crop improvement so a major thrust
of our work was first to expand research
on each theme independently
however an innovative emphasis will be
to address the interaction among the
themes as shown in this slide by the
light gray arrows in partnership with
our priority setting team we are working
to develop and adapt methods that take
account of those interactions to explain
and address them while also accepting
that priorities will vary by crop and
country context among other variables
for example let's consider one
relationship between gender equality and
nutrition
new bio-fortified varieties may be
developed and intended for home
consumption to improve food security and
household nutrition
in rwanda high iron bean varieties
also turned out to be higher yielding
and have become a lucrative cash crop as
a result women's activities in bean
production processing and trading are
changing
some have joined cooperatives
that have helped them to maintain
decision-making control over seed
selection and sales
considering potential interactions and
trade-offs early in the product
development process and initiating
household dialogues and producer
cooperatives can increase adoption while
ensuring that
we achieve the goal of do no harm
we are also thinking about good
practices to get young men and women
more involved in crop research for
example supporting them as students and
hiring them as researchers and
technicians
research programs can deliberately seek
out young agri entrepreneurs as input
suppliers or seed distributors of for
example new drought resistant varieties
illustrating thus a link between youth
and resilience
our goal is to carry out new research
that deliberately positions attention to
these themes and considers the needs of
end users in our research programs
if we are to be successful
then by the end of the project we will
not only have succeeded in fostering
solid research on each theme but also to
have strengthened our understanding of
how each theme interacts with each other
and the breeding process
the draft theory of change shown here
illustrates how we plan to address the
cross-cutting themes in our four primary
areas of work
research capacity development
coordination and engagement and
monitoring evaluation and learning
we have ongoing and planned activities
to incorporate all of the cross-cutting
themes some of which are shown in the
slide in the yellow boxes
we are confident that this work will
lead to important outputs and ultimately
help to change how crop improvement
research is conducted thus the expected
outcomes shown in the blue boxes all
reflect transformation in the way that
you'll see researchers in the areas of
inquiry and in the centers of innovation
will incorporate cross-cutting themes
research in identifying crop improvement
products using cross-cutting themes
knowledge skills and tools to identify
and adapt inclusive strategies in their
work and monitoring their progress
as we enter the end of the second year
of the program the cross-cutting themes
research is finally taking off a very
exciting new investigation will delve
into the relationships among the
interdisciplinary and international
agricultural research teams that are the
basis of ilc research and seek to
understand the way these teams interact
how they make decisions whose voice is
heard and how
although similar research on power
dynamics has been done in corporate
settings it is neither well documented
nor researched in agricultural research
we anticipate that gaining a rigorous
analysis from this research will enable
us to model more collaborative
interdisciplinary and equitable team
arrangements
the findings of the power dynamics
research will link up to research on
successful strategies for cross-cutting
themes integration
also still in its early stages this work
will include a capacity assessment and
an analysis of both institutional and
individual capacity
the centers of innovation teams are
doing research on these themes that has
focused on collecting and analyzing data
on trait preferences among different
value chain actors
each of the cois is currently working on
this topic using both quantitative and
qualitative methods to collect data from
different stakeholders
the next step of collating and
structuring such data to be utilized in
the breeding process
is less well articulated we are
therefore exploring the g plus tools
that have been developed by cgiar
researchers from the gender and breeding
initiative and the work of researchers
on the rtb foods project to identify
consumer preferences around sensory
characteristics of different varieties
another upcoming activity may include
attention to gender and youth in seed
delivery systems that is still under
development but we hope it can be
approved and started in year three of
the project
designing and putting in place the
capacity development activities shown
here has been a major emphasis over the
first two years the team initially
offered guidance to the coi applicants
to encourage their thinking about these
issues in the design of their work
programs
we continue to provide targeted support
to researchers when requested
this year we started a series of
webinars on individual cross-cutting
theme topics both methodological and
conceptual that are open to all lc
researchers and staff
another activity has been the creation
of online sensitization trainings for
each cross-cutting theme each covers the
four sessions shown emphasizing their
relevance to crop improvement these will
be hosted on the lc website and publicly
available
we are hopeful that we can offer two
different in-person
short courses over the next two years
one builds on the excellent work of
colleagues from the gender responsive
researchers equipped for agricultural
transformation or great project and its
curriculum on gender and crop reading
the second program builds on work done
by the integrating gender and nutrition
within agricultural extension systems
project that was led by the university
of illinois urbana-champaign
it will introduce a method for assessing
agricultural technologies for their
attention to our cross-cutting themes
so this slide should really show a large
zoom gallery as all of our meetings on
coordinating and engaging with other ilc
researchers have been virtual since
february 2020.
the process of consultation and support
derives directly from the lc vision that
national breeding programs are the
drivers of their own research programs
the cross-cutting themes team is
committed to avoiding top-down
directives and seeks instead
and seeks instead to support and
coordinate the engagement helping to
identify where cross-cutting themes can
be addressed and ensuring their
inclusion in the research activities as
well as supporting inclusivity and
diversity in institutional and project
policies and practices
we hold regularly scheduled and ad hoc
meetings with coi teams often jointly
with the priority setting teams the
agendas are typically set by the cois
and provide updates on research progress
and review of questions on methods and
approaches
i have already mentioned the team
strategy and the theory of change
and some of the core teams work is with
ilse management in planning coordination
and reporting
our last area of activity is monitoring
evaluation and learning we work with our
lc partner rti to provide feedback and
input into rti's mel design to capture
cross-cutting theme activities thus far
this has involved helping to frame the
relevant indicators to review each coi's
theory of change and to identify
opportunities to strengthen
implementation of cross-cutting themes
when appropriate
as i said at the start we continue to
learn from others the cgiar's gender in
breeding initiative has offered guidance
in developing gender responsive breeding
programs
we have done pretty well in applying
that guidance the four bullet points at
the top of the slide the coi teams are
interdisciplinary and each one is
carrying out research on trait
preferences disaggregated by sex and age
and by customers along the value chain
and the work of the priority setting
team is now developing or adapting
methods to address tradeoffs with
awareness of inclusivity
ilse is also expanding its guidance and
practices to address not only gender but
all four cross-cutting themes and their
mutually conditioning relationships as
shown in the figure
the key is in institutionalizing these
four components in each coi and in the
broader world of crop improvement
they include testing new tools and new
research approaches making adequate
investments to support this time and
labor-intensive collaborative
interdisciplinary work
changing attitudes and practices and
monitoring progress
we have made a good start and we look
forward to reporting back in a few years
on our accomplishments
thank you for your attention
i hope that the resources shown on this
slide will be a helpful guide to some of
the work that we are drawing on and to
our own work
thank you very much